فمنذ عشرين عاما بدات العربيه انطلاقتها
الاولى وعلى مدار هذه السنوات شهدت تطورات
متلاحقه في تقديم المحتوى والشكل ارست من
خلالها مفاهيم واساليب جديده للاعلام
العربي ليست فقط في قطاع الاخبار السياسيه
بل في مجال الاعلام المتخصص مجال الاعلام
الاقتصادي وهو ما استدعى اعاده اطلاق
محتوى ما يقدمه قسم الاقتصاد في قناه
العربيه وتحديدا خلال عام 2005 البدايه
كانت مع الاسواق العربيه بفريقها المتخصص
بخبره صحفيه واعلاميه واقتصاديه وماليه
والذي واكب اهم وابرز الاخبار والاحداث
والمتغيرات التي حركت جوانب الاقتصاد
وقادت مختلف قطاعات المال والاعمال محليا
في منطقه الخليج وفي مقدمتها السوق
السعوديه الاكبر من حيث القيمه السوقيه
بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا وعربيا وعالميا على مدار السنوات
الماضيه وحتى الان
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا
2006 كان العام الاكثر تقلبا لاسواق
المنطقه خاصه لسوق السعوديه بدءا من القمه
التي بلغها في التاسي في الخامس والعشرين
من فبراير فوق مستوى العشرين الف نقطه ثم
التقلبات الشديده في صباح 26 فبراير
وماتابعها من تغييرات وقرارات غيرت توجهات
السوق الماليه بالطبع كان لنشرات قسم
الاقتصاد في العربيه الحضور والتواجد
الاكثر بين اوساط المستثمرين والمهتمين
باسواق المال من السعوديين لمتابعه حزم
التغييرات التي اعقبت هبوط سوق الاسهم
والذي غير ثراء المستثمرين بالسعوديه بشكل
كامل
[تصفيق]
هذه مستويات قياسيه جديده نراها على سوق
الاسهم السعوديه ويبدو اننا نقترب جدا من
حاجز 21 الف نقطه اليوم ارتفاع 340 نقاط
او ما يعادل واحد ونصف في المئه على مؤشر
سوق الاسهم السعوديه الذي يقف الان عند 20
الف وتسعمائه اليوم سوق الاسهم السعوديه
تسجل تراجعات حاده الي يبدو انه عند
الاغلاق مؤشر السوق يخسر اكثر من ثلاثه في
المئه عدد كبير من الشركات تغلق على
انخفاض بالحد الاقصى المسموح به
لم تجاوز 7 مليار بينما تعودنا انها تجاوز
45 مليار او تقريبا مليار اربعين مليار
خلال الفتره الماضيه هذا يدلك على ان هناك
عدم قناعه كثيره في قضيه المضاربه
وبالتالي اتضحت المساله انه من الغير
المنطقي هذه الاسعار التي من الشركات
وبالتالي الجميع يرغب بالتخلص من هذه
الشركات
[موسيقى]
عالميا كان الزلزال الذي ضرب القطاع
المالي والمصرف الامريكي بانهيار بنكلي من
برادرز في منتصف سبتمبر 2008 وهو كان
بمثابه اشاره انطلاق اسوا ازمه اقتصاديه
ماليه منذ الثلاثينيات من القرن الماضي
كان هذا الافلاس الاشهر في تاريخ الامريكي
وبدا العالم يعاني من تبعات ازمه الرهن
العقاري كان يوما صعبا في ويت حيث فقد
مؤشر الداو 500 نقطه في اقوى تراجع منذ
هجمات 11 سبتمبر
2001 لاحقت بهذه الخسائر الحاده بقيمه
مؤشرات المال العالميه وايضا المحليه
انذاك ولعل من ابرز المشاهد التي ظلت
عالقه في اذهان العالم هي مغادره
المصرفيين لمقر البنك في ذلك اليوم
[موسيقى]
اوقات صعبه تعيشها الاسواق العالميه
والعربيه اليوم بعد ان استيقظ عالم
الاعمال على نبا تقدم بنك الاستثمار
العالمي لمن براذرز بطلب اعلاني افلاسه ما
يعرض النظام المالي الامريكي لازمه لامثله
لها
[موسيقى]
7341 نقطه هو مستوى المؤشر السعودي في هذه
اللحظات يسجل انخفاض باكثر من 5% من البيع
صباحا
يقول تغطيه مراكز مكشوفه والبعض يقول انه
فرص هناك فرص في السوق ولكن وجهه النظر
ترجح الاولى
[موسيقى]
اسواق الطاقه كان لها نصيب وافر من تصدر
عناوين الاسواق العربيه والتحديدا في
الحادي عشر من يوليو 2008 عندما سجلت
اسعار النفط اعلى مستوياتها على الاطلاق
متجاوزه علم 147 دولار للبرميل وذلك بسبب
عوامل عده منها التوترات
الى نيجيريا انذاك نتابع
[موسيقى]
سجل يوم امس 147 دولار فاصل 27 سنت
الاعاده عند الاغلاق ليغلق عن 144 دولار
و41 سنت بينما برنت قفز خلال جلسه
التعاملات الى 147 دولار ونصف وانهى
تداولات عن 144 دولار ونصف
150 دولار لم يصبح شيء بعيد المنال
اقتربنا منه كثيرا وبالتالي انا لا استبعد
ان نسمع من بعض المراقبين عن سقوط جديده
كان يصل الى 170 دولار او 200 دولار
[موسيقى]
ومنذ نحو 12 عاما وتحديدا في يناير 2011
شهدت الاقتصاد المصري احد ابرز التغييرات
التي تمتد اثارها حتى اليوم ضمن احداث
الربيع العربي انذاك وكرده فعل مباشر
للاحداث التي بدات شرارتها في الخامس
والعشرين من يناير شهدت البورصه المصريه
هبوطا تابعه ايقاف التداولات ل 38 جلسه
واصدار تعديلات لقوانين سوق المال وحدود
التداول لتتسارع الاحداث بعد ذلك بتعويم
الجنيه المصري في 2016 بقرار المركزي
المصري برئاسه طارق عامر انذاك ليتجاوز
السعر الرسمي حينها 20 جنيه ولاحقه بذلك
رفع متوالي لاسعار الفائده لاحتواء التضخم
الذي قفز فوق 30% ثم اللجوء الى الاقتراض
من صندوق النقد الدولي ثم تعوين ثاني
وثالث كما حدث مؤخرا في يناير الماضي
لتتجاوز العمله المصريه حاليا مستوى
الثلاثين جنيه مقابل الدولار واستق قفزات
سعريه غير مسبوقه
لاسعار السلع
[موسيقى]
تراجعات حاده في مطلع التداولات نراها على
البورصه المصريه
3.2% من الخسائر على مؤشر خسائر جدا اذا
قويه على مؤشر السوق في اول دقائق من
التداولاته
اكس 3.4% من الخسائر خسائر فادحه مستمره
لليوم الثاني في البورصه المصريه لا يسلم
اي سهم من هذه التراجعات وايضا الجنيه
المصري بدوره يسجل اليوم الثاني تراجعات
في السوق نلقي نظره عليه هو يسجل اذا ادنى
مستوياته او يصل عند ادنى مستوياته في سته
اعوام هذا دولار يسجل ارتفاع ب 0.3% على
الجنيه المصري
[موسيقى]
اوروبا ايضا مرت باصعب مواقفها منذ تاسيس
الاتحاد الاوروبي ومع اعلان تصويت لخروج
البريك بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي في
الثالث والعشرين من يونيو 2016 يوما ايضا
لن ننساه بقسم الاسواق العربيه
التغطيه الخاصه بفعل الحدث بالفعل هي
سابقه تاريخيه بعدما صوت البريطانيون
لصالح الخروج من الاتحاد الاوروبي بحوالي
52% مقابل 48% لصالح البقاء لتخرج
بريطانيا بعد ان ظلت لمده 43 عاما تحت
مظله الاتحاد الاوروبي تداعيات الهزه
الاقتصاديه عقب التصويت بالخروج من
الاتحاد طالت على المستوى السياسي رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني الذي اعلن استقالته
الاسماء المطروحه
لخلافه كامل في منصبه طبعا بدايه هناك وهو
طبعا عمده لندن السابق وهو ربما من ابرز
الشخصيات التي ايدت التخرج بريطانيا خسائر
فادحه سجلناها اليوم صباح اليوم على اسواق
الاسهم العالميه على السلع على الاسترليني
اليورو
وكلها سجلت تراجعات قويه مقابل ذلك راينا
ارتفاعات قويه على الملاذات الامنه مثل
الين والذهب وكذلك الدولار
وسنوات الثلاث الاخيره كانت ذات نوع فريد
وغريب من الاحداث وربما غير مسبوق تفشي
كوفيد 19 او فيروس كورونا الاسواق العربيه
تابعت اول باول رده فعل الجانب الاقتصادي
لنواحي الحياه في ظل تفشي كورونا
والاغلاقات التي طوقت العالم باسره لتصبح
الاكثر تاثيرا في اعمال واداء الشركات
والمستثمرين واسواق المال والاعمال
المستثمرون يهربون من الاسهم الى الدولار
والذهب مع اتساع رقعه تفشي الكورونا في
الاسواق الاسيويه تكتسد باللون الاحمر مع
اكتشاف حالات جديده على نطاق واسع بورصه
تكبدت خسائر لامست 4% وهي الاسوء منذ
عامين تقريبا حيث رفعت كوريا الجنوبيه
مستوى الانذار الى اعلى مستوى الاسواق
الاوروبيه هي الاخرى بدات تداولات الاسبوع
على تراجعات حاده فقد تراجع مؤشر القاره
الاوروبيه المركب باكثر من ثلاثه في المئه
وذلك بعد اغلاق بلدات ايطاليه نتيجه تفشي
الفيروس في حين تراجعت اسواق كل من فرنسا
والمانيا بنسبه تجاوزت الثلاثه في المئه
لم يكن مؤشر فوتسي البريطاني افضل حالا بل
تراجع ايضا باثنين فاصله سبعه على
الافتتاح مع استمرار ارتفاع عدد الوفيات
وايضا الاصابات اسعار النفط تسجل تراجعات
حاده وتعمق من هذه الخسائر
يخسر حوالي اربعه في المئه يتراجع بحدود
الاربعه في المئه ايضا نحن نتحدث الان
عن حاله من الهلع ما بين المستثمرين حاله
للتراجع لاخذ المخاطر
[موسيقى]
ومنذ نحو عام استيقظ العالم على خبر
اشتعال الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه لتطال
الحرب كل مدينه وكل قريه في اوروبا باسعار
ملتهبه لفواتير الغاز والوقود لتواجه
اوروبا اعلى تضخم لاسعار المستهلكين في
اربعين عاما
تراجع اسعار النفط بعد استبعاد الامدادات
من الموجه الاولى للعقوبات على روسيا
مقابل ارتفاعات في اسواق الاسهم لكن
الملفت في كل هذه العقوبات انها لم تشمل
شخص الرئيس الروسي لازمير بوتين ولم تشمل
تعليق روسيا من نظام تحويل الاموال لا اظن
ان القرار راح يكون فصل تام للقطاع الروسي
قيود تارجت لحتى يقدروا النظام الروسي
بدون ما ياذو الانترناشو التجاره الدوليه
ويقدروا ياخذوا من روسيا ويشتروا غاز ونفط
وقمح لكنها قدمت اعفاءات واسعه لمدفوعات
مشتريات النفط الخام والغاز الطبيعي
والوقود اضافه الى واردات الاغذيه كالحبوب
قرار بيبيه يوم امس بالتخرج من حصتها
البالغه 20% من حصه او من شركه راسنا بطبع
هي اكبر شركه وكل عام والعربيه بالف خير
عشرين عامه هذه فقط البدايه والمزيد من
النجاح نرتبط نرتقبه ونستعد اليه في هذه
القناه الاخباريه لنعتبرها جامعه للصحافه
ايضا